this morning CBS News is mourning the
loss of one of our own to the
coronavirus maria mckay tur who died at
54 was unique no matter what was going
on in her own life she always had time
to listen she battled health problems
for decades and used her deeps faith an
enormous smile to light up and inspire
others
she was the best of us Maria Mercator x'
career at CBS News spanned more than
three decades she rose from page two an
Emmy award-winning producer help guide
coverage of some of the biggest stories
but her last role as a talent executive
may have been her most fitting because
Maria was always a guiding spirit a
shining light ingrid Cyprian Matthews
was a close friend she was born in 1965
in New York City
her father Manuel was in finance on Wall
Street
her mother Gladys was an accomplished
pianist who spent her career touring
with the American Ballet Theatre Maria
adored her mom who inspired her lifelong
passion for the Arts exuberant
intelligent and fiercely loyal Maria was
a cheerleader for so many at CBS News
and beyond even while quietly dealing
with health troubles herself over 20
years she survived multiple battles with
cancer without an ounce of self-pity or
complaint dr. Valerie Roush was her
surgeon at Memorial sloan-kettering she
had an incredible drive and perseverance
I also saw her be a great patient
advocate for other cancer patients and
cancer survivors two years ago Maria
took a grand trip
with her father brother and
sister-in-law across Europe and North
Africa after all her health issues she
was thrilled to have this adventure with
her family still determined to get joy
out of life Maria Mercator was one
extraordinary woman and to so many of us
at CBS News our friend our confidante
our here
you got the news yesterday guys and it
was so hard to believe because she is
certainly rallied before and we were all
hoping that this would be the case it's
still hard to believe that we're not
going to see her anymore in the building
and it just shows you that this virus
does not discriminate and dismal for us
Anthony all right Thank You Gail you gay